Prof: Today we're
talking about Loyalists,
and in doing so we're going to
be talking about the range of
responses to the building crisis
in British America.
So basically over the course of
the first few lectures here,
we've looked at the logic
behind some British policy;
we've looked at the logic of
resistance.
Now we're seeing a little
momentum of resistance building
up,
so now also we need to look at
people who maybe are not as
eager to resist against the
British government,
and these are the Loyalists.
And it's going to seem sort of
opposite as to what I ought to
be doing at this moment,
but before we launch into
looking at the Loyalists I
actually want to go back for a
moment to the First Continental
Congress.
Partly because,
as you'll hear when I'm talking
about it,
it's actually the debates and
proceedings and outcome of this
First Continental Congress that
really helps crystallize matters
because,
as we'll see,
it really is 1774,1775 where
you begin to have people who
kind of identify themselves as
Loyalists.
And partly because,
as you'll see,
even in the First Continental
Congress itself there actually
were a range of opinions.
Not everybody in the Congress
agreed on the level of what
needed to be done.
So it's not as though in 1774
you had a blob of Patriot and
then a blob of Loyalist.
You had a spectrum of opinions
throughout society.
So let's look first at the
First Continental Congress in a
little bit more detail here,
just at the start of the
lecture.
And as I mentioned when I last
discussed the Congress,
it wasn't only composed of
radicals though,
as I'll discuss in a moment,
just the simple fact that this
Congress was called was a pretty
bold action.
But even so,
there was a range of opinions
represented in the Congress.
So there were some more radical
types present--
so you did have people like
Samuel Adams and Patrick Henry
there,
and already these people are
radical in their thoughts,
they're already pondering the
possibility of war--
you'll hear from Patrick Henry
in a moment--
but there were also moderates
there who were more in favor of
reconciliation or reform and who
hoped that the meeting of the
Congress would maybe show
Parliament that the colonies
were united and determined,
and that maybe the simple fact
that it met would inspire
Parliament to modify some of its
policies.
And as we'll see,
it ends up being that those who
were more radical in their
leanings ultimately have a
slight majority in this
Continental Congress and so in
the end they actually win the
day,
but it isn't obvious that
that's going to be the case at
the outset.
Now the delegates to this
Congress met in Philadelphia in
the beginning of September in
1774.
There were 55 men present and,
as I mentioned before,
most of them had some kind of
experience with politics in
their individual colonies.
Now if you do think about the
fact that this Congress existed,
just calling it into existence
was something of a radical act,
because if you think about it,
this is a colonial congress,
a self-appointed congress that
granted itself power of some
kind over all of the colonies
and even,
as we're about to see,
passed something that was in
the equivalent of legislation
that applied to all of the
colonies.
So in a sense that's a pretty
radical gesture.
And I found actually a satire
written in 1774 that does a good
job I think of showing how the
Congress did seem radical to
some and how to some it did not
represent happy,
good things that were about to
happen but actually represented
something frightening and out of
control.
And it's--Actually,
it's a broadside,
so it was a single sheet,
and this is a satire so it was
meant to be making fun of people
who were just elected to the
Continental Congress.
This is actually from New York
and it came out just after New
York had decided who was going
to go to the Continental
Congress from New York.
So these are people who were
just making fun of the whole
idea of having a Continental
Congress.
So it's a broadside and it's
made to look like a very formal
series of resolutions,
and actually it's titled
"A Meeting of the True Sons
of Liberty,"
and I--
after class I'll post a link to
it.
It's actually,
as is everything these days,
digitized so that you can
actually see what it looks like.
So the broadside--series of
resolutions, it reads:
"Number one.
Resolved, That in this general
Time of resolving,
we have as good a right to
resolve as the most
resolute."
Okay.
[laughter]
This is not a serious series of
resolutions.
"Number two.
Resolved: That we have the
whole Sense of the City,
County, Province,
and all the Colonies,
concentrated in our own
Persons."
Again something that's not
thrilling the people writing
these resolutions.
Number three.
"Resolved:
That these Resolves,
and any we may afterward see
fit to promulgate,
shall be approved by all
sensible and good Men in our
Parent Country;
and that [they shall]
even make that ungracious
Varlet,
Lord North--"
"Varlet"
is one of those words you don't
get to say very often.
It made me really happy to type
it today.
[laughs]--that ungracious
Varlet, Lord North,
it will make him "shake in
his Shoes (when he sees them)
and split his Breeches."
Okay.
The eternal joke of people
splitting their pants.
That dates back to 1774 and
practically earlier.
I would assume it goes earlier
than that, the eternal joke.
So Lord North will shake in his
shoes;
it will make him split his
breeches.
Resolve number four:
"That any Act or Acts of
Parliament which prevent the
Colonies from triumphing over
the Liberties,
sporting with the goods or at
Will claiming the Properties of
the British Ministry,
is a cruel Oppression in which
all the Colonies are intimately
concerned.
Resolved ...
.That the Non-Payment of Debts
contracted with England is the
only Way to save the Credit of
those who have no Money to pay
their Debts with."
Okay.
So that's attacking the logic
of people who don't want to pay
taxes.
Well, they just don't have
money and they don't feel like
paying.
Resolved: "That the best
Way of approving our Loyalty,
is to spit in the...
King's face;
as the means of opening his
Eyes."
Okay, and then finally, lastly:
Resolved: "That every Man,
Woman or Child,
who doth not agree with our
Sentiments,
whether he, she or they
understand them or not,
is an Enemy to his Country,
wheresoever he was born...
,whatever he may think of it;
and that he ought at least to
be tarred and feathered,
if not hanged,
drawn and quartered;
all Statutes,
Laws and Ordinances whatsoever
to the contrary
notwithstanding."
Okay.
[laughs]
So that satire clearly throws
within it a slew of accusations
against this pending Continental
Congress.
You can see that it's being
accused of being arbitrary,
of promoting lawlessness,
of having a lack of tolerance
for anybody who feels any
differently;
that it's being accused of
displaying a lack of respect or
gratitude towards the mother
country, maybe even
vindictiveness;
and--as it was clear in that
first,
"We resolve to be
resolving in this time of
resolving"--
they're also accusing it of
having a stupid amount of
self-importance,
right?
Continental Congress, harrumph.
Sure.
Go have your little Continental
Congress.
So any of the reasons would
have been part of the reasoning
why someone might have felt that
this Continental Congress was
not only not a good idea but
potentially a dangerous idea.
So for one reason or another,
people clearly found the
calling of the Continental
Congress somewhat remarkable.
So the Congress' first meeting
was on September 5,
and one of the first things
that they had to debate,
logically enough,
is how the Congress is going to
vote on issues.
Should voting be based on the
population of each colony,
which obviously gives bigger
colonies an advantage,
or should each colony have one
vote?
The eternal question.
Obviously, this is going to
come back and hit us with a
vengeance at the Constitutional
Convention.
Student: How did they
vote on that?
Prof: How'd they--
[laughs]
Oh, that's one of those
question-in-a-question
questions.
That's--I have not gone to look
at the record to see formally
how they voted on the voting.
I would assume they voted by
person, but I will have to
actually look that up to tell
you how they voted.
The question was how do you
vote on how you're going to
vote?
[laughs]
That's a really good question.
I will come in next time and
tell you the answer to that
question.
I had not considered that
before.
Okay. How do you vote on voting?
Okay.
So however you vote on voting,
that was one of the first
things that they had to debate--
was how voting was going to
work, and as I said it's going
to come back and smack us again
in the Constitutional
Convention.
Now this whole debate--voting
on voting--tried the patience of
Patrick Henry.
Okay.
Patrick Henry,
obviously one of the more
radical members of this First
Continental Congress,
really impatient at the idea
that they're dilly-dallying
about voting and how to
calculate population of
different colonies.
So this is what Henry said in a
burst of frustration.
"Government is dissolved
...
We are in a state of nature,
Sir ....
The distinctions between
Virginians, Pennsylvanians,
New Yorkers,
and New Englanders,
are no more.
I am not a Virginian but an
American."
Clearly, he has a real talent
for the bold statement,
the memorable bold statement--I
am not a Virginian but an
American--
kind of not as famous as the
liberty or death thing but still
clearly really bold,
also clearly referring to the
logic,
John Locke, social contract.
Just by saying that we're in a
state of nature,
Henry is basically saying that
the social contract between the
colonies and the Crown has been
broken.
Clearly, he's one of the more
radical members of Congress,
so everybody wouldn't hear what
he said and stand up and applaud
and line up.
'Yes, we're in a state of
nature.
Go.'
He's an extreme,
but in fact you can see
throughout the Continental
Congress tension between a real
spectrum of opinions.
There were militant members
really promoting resistance,
even already kind of thinking
maybe war is on the horizon,
and then there were more
moderate members promoting
reconciliation or maybe reform
of some kind.
And you can see the push of the
more militant members and the
sort of debate between the
different kinds of opinions
almost immediately within the
first few weeks of meeting,
with the arrival of what came
to be called the Suffolk
Resolves--
Suffolk, Massachusetts,
S-u-f-f-o-l-k.
And again--obviously Suffolk,
Massachusetts--not
surprisingly,
these what you will see as
being very bold resolutions
originate in Massachusetts.
But they were not introduced by
Massachusetts delegates.
This is something John Adams
does later too.
Because Massachusetts is such a
radical colony people--
delegates from Massachusetts
know that they had better not be
the ones to promote anything
that sounds radical because
everybody will immediately
dismiss it.
So in this case the
Massachusetts delegates know if
they come forward and say,
'We brought these resolves;
we want you to consider them,'
people would probably assume
that they were too extreme,
but if they appear to come from
Massachusetts to the Continental
Congress,
well, then that becomes
something that people will be
more open to considering.
So this set of resolves was
sent to the Congress supposedly
from Suffolk County,
Massachusetts,
which is I guess Boston's
county,
and they became known as the
Suffolk Resolves,
so here is a list of some of
the things that these declared.
Okay.
Number one: They declared the
Intolerable Acts or the Coercive
Acts--
however you want to refer to
them--as being unconstitutional
and not to be obeyed.
Number two: They said that
Massachusetts--
which you remember that their
government had been dissolved,
things had been changed because
of everything that had been
going on in Boston--
Massachusetts should create a
new assembly for itself to
collect all colonial taxes and
withhold them from the Crown
until the Massachusetts
government had been restored to
its constitutional foundation.
Number three:
The resolves advised people to
arm themselves and form their
own militia in preparation for
resisting the possibility of
British attack.
Number four:
They proposed that the jailing
of any patriot leader gave
people the right to jail British
officials.
And then finally,
they recommended stringent
economic sanctions against
Britain.
Okay.
Clearly, those are really
radical resolutions on a bunch
of levels.
Now they were proposed;
they were read;
they were presented.
Some in the Continental
Congress applauded them but they
were not initially acted on for
obvious reasons,
because they made a lot of
delegates extremely nervous.
As delegate Joseph Galloway of
Pennsylvania said,
the Suffolk Resolves,
quote, "contained a
complete declaration of war
against Great Britain."
Okay.
They seemed pretty extreme.
Galloway was typical of many
who felt that just failing to
recognize Parliament's right to
regulate trade didn't accomplish
anything,
and as a matter of fact he
wasn't even sure that that was
right in theory.
So Galloway at this moment came
up with his own suggestion about
the best course of action.
And although in comparison with
the really radical Suffolk
Resolves his suggestions are
going to sound conservative,
he actually are promoting ideas
that in and of themselves,
as you'll hear, are radical.
So basically Galloway tries to
come up with a way to change the
basis of the relationship
between the American colonies
and the mother country.
And so he suggests a new plan
of union that he thinks are
going to--it's going to settle
the whole matter.
So Galloway's plan of union
suggested forming a separate
American legislature.
He called it,
I think, the Grand Council,
and it would be elected by
colonial assemblies.
And individual colonies would
continue to govern their own
internal affairs and the Grand
Council would regulate
commercial,
civil and criminal matters that
affected the colonies generally
as a whole.
Now according to Galloway's
plan, this Grand Council could
veto parliamentary legislation--
clearly that's a pretty bold
gesture--
but still it would be inferior
to Parliament,
which could still initiate
legislation relevant to the
colonies.
In essence the Grand Council
would be kind of an inferior
branch of the British
Parliament.
And the great principle behind
Galloway's plan was,
quote, "that no law should
bind America without her
consent."
So that's really what he's
trying to do here is devise a
way for the colonists to consent
to what's being passed in
Parliament.
Now interestingly,
the vote over Galloway's plan
of union was close but it was
ultimately defeated,
and I suppose looking back in
the long view of time it
probably wasn't likely that the
British government would have
approved of the creation of a
kind of second colonial
parliament.
And, as we'll see,
that's unlikely particularly
when you look later at how
Parliament responded to these
continental congresses,
and in a sense you could say
the Continental Congress was a
sort of temporary version of a
Grand Council.
So the fact that Parliament
wasn't too keen on that would
suggest they wouldn't be very
excited about a little baby
colonial parliament--
branch of Parliament being
established.
Even so, Galloway later
declared that his plan lost due
to what he called the violent
party,
and he felt the violent party
was in control of the
Continental Congress,
and in a sense he was right
because the more radical members
did have a very slight majority.
And the defeat of Galloway's
plan actually ended up
mobilizing these more radical
members because it suggested
that the moderates didn't have
the power to accomplish their
goals.
So with this new burst of
confidence in their strength,
with the defeat of Galloway's
plan,
these radicals proposed and
passed the Suffolk Resolves on
October 8,1774.
So they actually passed them.
To many in Congress,
this seemed like an incredibly
bold act of unity among the
colonies,
and even though the individual
resolves were radical,
to many what they noticed most
of all was that it appeared to
be an act of unity.
In a sense it was responding to
Massachusetts and to
Massachusetts' plight with an
action that would affect all of
the colonies.
As John Adams put it,
"This day convinced me
that America will support ...
Massachusetts or perish with
her," so he took it like
many others as a really
interesting sign of colonial
unity.
Now of course not everybody had
such a thrilled reaction to the
Suffolk Resolves.
One completely baffled Loyalist
observer said that he could only
explain the acceptance of the
Suffolk Resolves by assuming
that the delegates,
quote, "came into this
vote immediately after drinking
thirty-two bumpers of the best
Madeira."
Okay.
They just must have been drunk.
[laughs]
There is no other explanation.
This makes no sense.
[laughs]
The eternal explanation for all
of history: I guess they must
have been drunk or crazy.
Okay.
So clearly, a sure sign here
that the colonies are not just
going to be backing down.
Six days later on October 14,
Congress approved the
Declaration and Resolves--
and they had agonized over that
for a month so they didn't just
pass it;
they actually had been
pondering it all along.
And the Declaration and
Resolves actually represented
one of the goals of this
Continental Congress--to write a
clear statement of colonial
rights.
However, this was not as easy
as it might sound because
America was pretty much
following an uncharted path.
Never before in Western history
had colonies dared to rebel
against the mother country in
quite this way,
so now they had to somehow put
on paper a way to justify it.
Why were they doing this and as
important--
actually in a sense maybe more
could all of the colonies agree
on the specifics of colonial
rights?
Could they actually even sit
down and make a statement that
everybody agreed on?
And the difficulties that the
delegates had in writing this
draft really demonstrates once
again how really difficult it
was to define the precise terms
of the colonies' problem with
the mother country,
the precise terms for the
proper relationship between the
colonies and the mother country.
Even when they sat down to do
it--'Okay.
Here we are,
the committee in the First
Continental Congress,
and we're going to form the
Declaration and Resolves and
write down the reasons for our
actions.'
Even with such deliberate
desire on their part,
it was difficult for them to
commit this to writing.
It was difficult for them to
find the right words and to
agree.
And the Declaration and
Resolves was drafted by a
committee.
John Adams was on the committee
--which is good because then he
gets to tell us afterwards about
the creation of the Declaration
and Resolves because he always
likes to explain his role in
every important moment of the
American Revolution.
So he was there.
And the committee ended up
basically stating in their draft
that the Declaration and
Resolves were going to be based
on three things.
Their explanation for what was
going on in the colonies was
going to be based on three
things: Number one,
the laws of nature;
number two, the principles of
the English constitution;
and number three,
the charters of the colonies.
So all of those things,
the laws of nature,
the principles of the English
constitution,
the charters of the colonies,
all of those things were cited
as justification for what was
going on,
but in a sense the real basis
of what was coming out here in
the Declaration and Resolves--
and so in a sense what they
were really most grounded on--
was going to be their sense of
rights as English subjects,
the power of Parliament.
It was really going to be their
understanding of the English
constitution.
And you can hear how important
this particular fact was to them
just in looking at the list of
colonial rights that they
included in this declaration as
being violated.
So they listed that the right
of assembly was being violated,
the right of petition,
the right to be tried by a jury
of their peers,
the right to be free of a
standing army,
the right to choose their own
assemblies.
All of these things are really
basic English constitutional
rights that these colonists are
starting they feel they've been
violated.
As John Adams later explained,
the biggest challenge in
drafting the declaration was in
describing what he called,
quote, "the authority of
Parliament."
What he said was the authority
of Parliament was "indeed
the essence of the whole
controversy;
some were for a flat denial of
all authority;
others for denying the power of
taxation only;
some for denying internal,
but admitting external,
taxation."
So even within this little
committee--
there's only a few people on
the committee--
even there, there are all these
opinions on exactly what's
supposed to be happening in the
relationship with the mother
country.
And as Adams puts it,
"After a multitude of
motions had been made,
discussed, negatived,
it seemed as if we should never
agree upon anything."
So they just can't state what
their resolves are.
However, ultimately they
managed to do it.
John Adams did a lot towards
contributing one particular
article in this document that
said Parliament could not tax
them,
but the colonies would
"cheerfully"
submit to bona fide regulation
of external commerce.
So we have two things. Right.
We have the Suffolk Resolves.
We have the Declaration and
Resolves.
The Continental Congress also
drafted a petition to the King
and it was a restrained--
it was a respectful petition
basically trying to inform the
King of the evil plot hatching
in Parliament to rob the
colonies of their rights.
The petition warned the King
that there were,
quote, "designing and
dangerous men"
in Parliament,
and that they were trying to
intervene between the King and
his faithful subjects.
Now clearly you can hear at
this point, the focus here is on
Parliament.
By petitioning the King,
this Congress is suggesting
that the King is really still a
figure who can be reasoned with,
that the King is someone who
they're appealing to in person
to help with the problem with
Parliament.
Okay.
Suffolk Resolves,
Declaration and Resolves,
petition to the King.
The final thing that the
Congress did was agree on a way
to secure the repeal of all
offensive parliamentary
legislation.
And they decided to do this in
the way that they had always
protested British attacks on
their rights--surprise,
surprise--non-importation.
Right?
They think that always works,
non-importation;
we're going back to
non-importation.
But this time they decided to
really form a network of local
non-importation committees and
towns throughout the colonies to
actually enforce
non-importation.
They called their plan the
Continental Association,
so clearly this is more
ambitious at least in what
they're suggesting it is,
in their desire for what they
want it to be.
And as it happened before,
they included in their plan
localized Committees of
Inspection that would watch to
see who's violating the boycott,
who's drinking tea,
who's buying luxuries.
Now, the creation of the
Continental Association didn't
just encourage non-importation.
It actually had a number of
other impacts on the colonies as
a whole and on sort of what's
developing in the colonies.
First, by creating the
Continental Association and
ensuring that it was going to
have a really widespread,
localized influence,
the Continental Congress
essentially created a localized
government structure that down
the road would be vital in
organizing the war effort and
maintaining order throughout the
war.
So they're creating kind of a
network--just by declaring that
this exists--that goes
throughout the colonies.
Second, in the process of doing
that the Association brought
literally thousands of people
into the war effort as committee
members.
Third, although the Continental
Congress was an unofficial
congress that didn't have any
real authority,
by creating the Continental
Association it basically passed
a piece of legislation that
applied throughout the colonies.
Committees of Inspection
considered themselves the
enforcement agencies of the
Continental Congress,
not enforcement agencies
of their local colonial
legislature,
and in some colonies committees
actually created--
I'm sorry--communities actually
created Committees of Inspection
on their own,
without even waiting for their
own colonial legislature to ask
them,
or even for it to meet.
They just knew that this was
happening and communities in and
of themselves created their own
Committees of Inspection.
And then fourth,
over time as the colonies moved
into war and as colonial
governments really began to
falter and run into
complications--
as the crisis really
magnified--these Committees of
Inspection were able to step
into the void and assert some
kind of centralized organized--
hopefully--authority.
Okay.
So the Continental Association
went into effect and this time,
more than any of the previous
attempts at non-importation,
people really are beginning to
realize that there's a crisis at
hand,
so more people complied with
non-importation now than ever
before.
And at times before it had been
successful, but now we actually
reach a new high of people
complying with this.
And just one example of this:
In 1774, New York imported
roughly 437,000 pounds sterling
worth of British goods.
Okay, 437 pounds sterling.
One year later,
1775, in New York this number
had dropped to roughly 1,000
pounds sterling.
Okay. That's huge. Right?
That's real compliance with
non-importation.
And the Congress' final act was
to agree to meet the following
spring in May of 1775 if their
grievances had not been
addressed by that time.
So basically they conclude by
saying, 'Okay.
We're going to now give Britain
time to hear what we've
said--the several months it's
going to take it to get across
the ocean to England.
They can respond and take
several months to communicate
back with us and we'll see what
happens,
and if we haven't been
addressed we will have another
continental congress in May of
1775.'
Now as you can imagine,
the adjournment of the First
Continental Congress left
relations between the colonies
and the mother country in kind
of a precarious state.
The Congress and its activities
also made it increasingly
obvious that there were two
sides forming on the question of
the proper workings of the
imperial system and how best to
respond to the ongoing problem.
Now all along,
there had been people who had
more sympathy towards the Crown
than others,
people like Massachusetts
governor Thomas Hutchinson--
he is now Governor--or like the
people throughout the colonies
who accepted the position of
stamp distributor,
for example.
By late 1774 and 1775,
as people really began to take
sides and warfare began to seem
at least possible to some
people,
the people who were sympathetic
to the British administration
began to face some difficult
choices.
Known at this point as the
King's Friends or the Friends of
Government,
they began to find it more and
more difficult if not impossible
to remain neutral.
Thousands of people were
becoming involved in the war
effort.
Troops, which of course in
Boston they called,
quote, "military
executioners"--
They had a real flair for
propaganda in Boston.
Troops, whether you called them
military executioners or not,
were being sent to America in
increasing numbers.
So people were beginning to
take sides,
and those who felt loyal to the
British government had to decide
on a course of action,
because to not declare your
loyalty to the protesting
colonists was often as good as
declaring your enmity to them.
Many Loyalists would soon
declare with some justification
that by forcing people to sign
oaths--
like, they were loyal to the
Patriot cause,
by inspecting people's
purchases to see if they were
complying with non-importation--
that the Continental
Association was supposedly
fighting for American liberty by
curbing individual liberties.
As one Loyalist wrote,
the only liberty that the
Patriots wanted was the liberty,
quote, "of knocking out
any Man's Brains that dares
presume to speak his Mind freely
upon the present Contest."
Okay.
These are people who are
beginning to feel irked that
there seems to be a majority
building in some way,
certainly a loud group of
people expressing anger and
resentment and resistance,
and if you don't agree,
people are beginning to feel
somewhat threatened.
Now traditionally these
Loyalists have often been
depicted as timid or
conservative men who maybe were
too afraid to side with the
rebels,
maybe were afraid to fight the
system,
or were afraid of losing their
wealth or status,
but obviously the truth is more
complex than that.
Choosing to remain loyal to the
Crown in the midst of a building
resistant movement was not an
easy choice.
And ultimately it really
required in some cases some
degree of bravery,
because it really did put your
livelihood,
your property,
and even sometimes your
physical safety at risk because
it potentially forced you to put
yourself on the opposing side
from your friends,
sometimes even your family.
Actually, a couple
of--Actually,
a good number of years ago,
I had someone write a senior
essay with me and he found a
diary from roughly this period
of a person whose family--
he was from New England and I
don't remember where he was
from--
his family divided over what to
do.
And half of the family felt
like they wanted to remain loyal
to the Crown and half didn't,
and the diary is really
fascinating.
It just shows this person
trying to figure out what to do
and no matter what he does,
actually, members of his family
are going to cut him off.
And it really--It was a good
senior essay if I do say so
myself--
but it also was really a
fascinating diary because it
just really showed one family
being just torn apart by
increasingly passionate
political ideas but equally
important by just having to take
a stand in a community that's
swaying one way or another.
And you can see what I'm
talking about.
Actually, it's another diary
and this one I have a quote from
as opposed to the random senior
essay I'm remembering from years
past.
There's a diary of a fellow
named Samuel Curwen.
He did not describe himself as
a Loyalist.
He described himself as a,
quote, "moderate
man"--
and I'm going to come back to
that too,
that Loyalist and moderate are
not always the same thing--
but he described himself as a
moderate man and he said that
until 1775 he lived in
Massachusetts.
Obviously, by 1775 it would be
difficult to be a moderate man,
and in 1775 after Lexington and
Concord,
Curwen became actually fearful
for his life in that radical
colony.
So as he put it,
"I left my late peaceful
home (in my sixtieth
year)," so he's been living
there for 60 years "in
search of personal security,
and those rights which by the
laws of God,
I ought to have enjoyed
undisturbed there."
So he's a moderate and he feels
actually threatened in
Massachusetts and he decides he
needs to move,
so he heads to Philadelphia
hoping,
as he put it,
"to find an asylum amongst
Quakers and Dutchmen."
So he's actually seeking out a
population of people who maybe
aren't going to be as radical as
the people he's coming from.
And he says in his diary that
when he arrived in Philadelphia
a friend came to meet his boat
at the dock and this friend's
opening remark--
so the first thing that the
friend said to him--
was, "We will protect you,
though you're a Tory,"
and this guy said,
it "embarrassed me not a
little."
Okay.
So he basically feels like--and
he says this at one point--he
feels like he has the mark of
Cain.
No matter where he goes people
are sort of like:
'oh, you're a Tory,
are you?
Well, we'll protect you because
we like you.'
And he said he found it very
difficult to find a place to
stay, to find a boarding house
in Philadelphia,
because people just refused to
take him in.
As he put it,
"so many refused as made
it fearful whether,
like Cain, I had not a
discouraging mark upon me,
or a strong feature of
Toryism"--
like somehow people are looking
at me and saying I look like a
Tory?
Like, how was it that they
weren't giving me any place to
stay?
So that's one person's diary,
but again it shows you how this
person felt threatened and then
this person,
even having moved to feel
safer, ends up in Philadelphia
and still feels as though he's
certainly outside of the
majority and not having an easy
time of it even among his
friends.
So clearly choosing to remain
loyal to the Crown,
or even like Curwen just
choosing to be moderate in your
principles,
could be a really difficult
choice with some pretty serious
consequences.
Now--there were many reasons
why one might choose to remain
loyal to the Crown or to be
moderate.
And in a way just sort of using
the term "Loyalist"
and throwing it around doesn't
do the complexity of this
justice,
because there were any number
of reasons why you might not
want to go along with colonial
resistance.
Some people maybe were really
aggressively loyal to the Crown.
Maybe that was where their
actions were coming from.
Maybe some people just were not
excited about the idea of
independence and war,
and maybe that would have been
their breaking point.
Some, like the Quakers,
may have been just trying to
remain neutral or pacifist,
which, as you've just heard,
could be a difficult thing to
do.
And some, probably like this
Curwen, might have just wanted
to be aloof from the whole
matter and--again--did not find
that very easy to do.
After the war,
Dr. Benjamin Rush--
who, as you'll hear in this
little quote,
was obviously supportive of
colonial resistance--
explained that to him there had
been four different kinds of
Torys during the Revolution.
Okay.
This is Rush's category of
Tories.
Quote: "There were...
Furious Tories who had recourse
to violence and even to
arms...."
There were "Writing and
talking Tories"--which I
always think:
as opposed to the illiterate
mute Tories?
[laughter]
And obviously he's saying,
the ones who were really loud,
okay, but still.
So there are furious Tories,
writing and talking Tories,
"Silent but busy
Tories" who are
"disseminating Tory
pamphlets and newspapers and...
circulating intelligence,"
and then number four:
"Peaceable and
conscientious Tories who
patiently submitted to the
measures of the governing
powers,
and who showed nearly equal
kindness to the distress of both
parties during the war."
This is Rush's way of looking
at things,
and clearly that's his own
little eccentric point of view,
but let's talk for a minute
here about what we're talking
about in the way of numbers,
as far as how many Loyalists
are there,
what are we talking about
roughly percentage-wise.
Historians estimate that
roughly fifteen to twenty
percent of white males were
Loyalist by the war's end,
and in this sense,
when I'm using the word
"Loyalist"
here,
I'm actually meaning people who
did something overt to support
the Crown during the Revolution,
like signing addresses,
bearing arms against the
continental troops,
doing business with the British
army,
seeking military protection
from the British army or going
into exile.
So just people who were doing
those activities:
fifteen to twenty percent of
white males.
When you add to that percentage
those who just wanted to avoid
involving themselves in the
struggle you end up with roughly
half of the white male colonists
not falling into the category of
"Patriot"
or,
if you use a term that the
Loyalists would have used,
"rebel."
So all in all,
only about half of the white
male population actively
supported colonial resistance,
and at different times of the
war, depending on the immediate
circumstances,
obviously people changed their
views.
Now there were any number of
reasons to stay loyal to the
Crown,
and I'm guessing--certainly if
I hadn't studied this time
period I would assume that there
is this stereotypical image of
the Tory who one would assume is
this sort of aristocratic
person,
this really rich person in a
very fancy wig with very fancy
clothes,
taking snuff and doing a
variety of other aristocratic
eighteenth-century gentry kind
of things and sort of sneering
at the rebels.
I think there's sort of some
stereotype we have in our brain
about who Tories are,
but as a matter of fact they
were--some Tories fit into that
category but certainly not all.
Wealth and poverty,
high status and low,
every kind of ethnicity could
be found on both sides of the
crisis,
and from colony to colony
different kinds of people chose
different sides depending on
regional circumstances.
So for example:
In New York a lot of the landed
gentry tended to be Loyalist.
In Virginia,
the landed gentry tended to not
be Loyalist.
In Massachusetts,
small farmers tended to be
Patriots.
In New York and North Carolina
the--or at least the up-country
of North Carolina--small farmers
did not necessarily tend to be
Patriots.
So it obviously varied region
by region, depending on local
circumstances.
In general terms--In very
general terms,
you could say that Loyalism was
stronger in the middle states
than in New England and stronger
in the lower South than in the
upper South,
and very strong particularly in
New York,
which the British ended up
holding throughout most of the
war,
and weakest in Massachusetts,
Virginia and Connecticut.
Connecticut stood up.
But there's a reason for that
because those are among the
oldest colonies with a very long
tradition of self-government,
aggressive self-government.
Scholars who have studied
Loyalists have noted that there
seemed to be several types of
people who ended up being more
likely to become Loyalists.
One likely Loyalist--and this
won't be surprising--
would have been people who were
connected with the British
government by some kind of an
official appointment,
or were related to somebody who
had an official royal
appointment.
For these people remaining
loyal was not necessarily due to
self-interested reasons,
although certainly
self-interest could have played
a part,
but as important loyal
officeholders or people related
to them had closer contact with
the British government than most
others,
and thus they were better able
to see the logic of politics in
England,
so they had more reason to be
skeptical of claims about a
conspiracy afoot in England to
destroy colonial rights.
For example,
Thomas Hutchison up in
Massachusetts was honestly
baffled by the accusation that
there was a plot against
colonial liberties and that
somehow he was part of it.
He knew that he personally
wasn't conspiring against the
colonies,
so he wasn't quite sure what
people were talking about,
and because of that he had good
reason to doubt the enterprise
of what was going on.
So that's one potential
Loyalist.
A second kind of person who
tended to become a Loyalist
was--
again logically enough--people
who were in a religious or
cultural minority,
and who thus already felt a
little defensive and not
necessarily trusting in the whim
of the majority--
or the whim of the angry,
resistant majority.
And I'm going to go into this
in more detail in a future
lecture,
but for logical reasons a good
many African-American slaves
ended up becoming Loyalists for
good reason having to do with
the chance of earning their
freedom.
So that's a second kind.
A third kind of Loyalist
consisted of people who lived
out in the hinterlands in the
backcountry away from the
eastern seaboard.
And this is for a couple of
reasons,
but one of the main ones is,
if you think about it the main
vehicle or one of the main
vehicles for radical ideas would
have been newspapers.
And newspapers largely
circulated in large port cities.
And I've quoted already a
number of times from the
Boston Gazette,
which would have been hard
to get out in the hinterland
somewhere.
Tories called the Boston
Gazette--
That's where Samuel Adams
wrote a lot of his things--
Tories called the Boston
Gazette the "Weekly
Dung Barge."
[laughs]
I think everybody just wins
here in the propaganda game.
It's equally impressive on all
sides in the propaganda game.
People out in the frontier in
Virginia or the Carolinas who
didn't have a lot of access to
newspapers might have been
harder to convince of a great
plot against their liberties.
As one historian wrote,
"Not having been exposed
to the 'disease,' how could they
catch it?"
None of these people had a
particular reason to be swept up
in the resistance movement,
and they had reasons to resist
it.
By 1774, all of these
people--royal officeholders,
cultural or religious
minorities, people living out on
the frontier--
were conscious minorities,
people who felt either weak or
threatened,
particularly considering raging
events in cities along the
seaboard.
So in a way,
you could say that many
Loyalists were simply more
afraid of the rebelling colonies
than they were of the Crown.
Almost all of them had
interests that they felt needed
protection from a raging
American majority.
Now these Loyalists did not
necessarily have vast
ideological differences from
people who came to be known as
the American Patriots,
but they might have,
and in fact some Loyalists
actually believed precisely what
the rebels believed in reverse.
So in the same way that the
colonists thought there was this
plot forming in Parliament to
curb colonial liberties,
some Loyalists saw a plot
forming among radical colonists
who were falsely claiming to
represent the people.
Right?
That makes perfect sense.
Many of these Loyalists did not
part with the colonial majority
until well into the imperial
crisis,
and for many,
as we'll see,
it's not until independence
becomes probable,
and when real,
actual separation from the
mother country is at hand,
that they felt compelled to
declare their loyalty to the
Crown and actually break away.
This was actually part of the
agony of the Revolution,
the fact that many people just
weren't sure of what they should
do.
They weren't sure how they felt
about the crisis.
They weren't sure what side to
take.
They weren't sure that they
wanted to take a side.
They weren't sure what would
happen if they did.
And on all sides people still
cared about the colonies.
They just had different visions
about the right course of
action--
and people had to just make
these sorts of decisions about
their loyalties on an individual
level,
and obviously there were many
different levels of loyalty to
the British government.
So I suppose what I'm saying
here--I'll wrap it up here.
In a sense, it's really easy to
analyze and pass judgment on the
decision to become a Loyalist,
but I think it's just as easy
to analyze and pass judgment on
the decision to resist the
Crown.
I think one way or another,
people were evaluating what was
happening.
People were thinking about what
they thought the proper course
of action should be and then
making individual choices for
any number of reasons,
some of them ideological,
some of them personal,
having to do with your family,
having to do with your
livelihood,
having to do with your safety
and security.
So one way or another,
making this decision was kind
of an extreme act.
And the period that we're now
at in this course--1774,1775--is
precisely when those sorts of
decisions have to be made.
We'll be talking about
Common Sense on Thursday,
which does a lot towards
pushing some people into making
a pretty radical decision.
I will see you on Thursday.
Those of you did not turn in
your papers, turn them in to
your T.F.